اعلن البيت الابيض ان الولايات المتحده
مستعده لتقديم كل المساعدات اللازمه
لتركيا لافتا الى صدور توجيه من الرئيس جو
بايدن في هذا الصدد بدورها روسيا ارسلت
ثلاثه طائرات تابعه لوزاره الطوارئ
الروسيه على متنها اكثر من مئه من رجال
الانقاذ والاطباء وفي السياق اعلنت الصين
عن تقديم دفعه الاولى بقيمه نحو سته
ملايين دولار كمساعدات طارئه لجهود
الاغاثه في تركيا
بريطانيا ارسلت فريقا من 76 متخصصا في
البحث والانقاذ وعبرت عن استعدادها لتقديم
مزيد من الدعم وقال وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه البريطاني انهم سيستخدمون كل شيء
من اجل ادخال المساعدات لشمال سوريا مؤكدا
مواصله دعم الخوادي البيضاء والمنظمات
الخيريه العامله كما قالت هيئه الحمايه
المدنيه الاتحاديه بالمانيا انها ستقدم
مخيمات ملاجئ طوارئ ووحدات لمعالجه المياه
النمسا اعلن مستشارها عن ارسال 80 جنديا
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ وتقديم ثلاثه
ملايين يورو كما اعلنت الخارجيه
الاستراليه تقديم مساعدات انسانيه مبدئيه
بقيمه عشره ملايين دولار للمتضررين من
الزلازل التي ضربت تركيا والسوريه في سياق
متصل قررت قطر فتح جسر جوي لتركيا يضم فرق
انقاذ وطواقم طبيه ومساعدات اغاثيه وخياما
ومستلزمات وقالت الخارجيه القطريه ان نائب
رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اكد
لنظيره التركي خلال اتصال هاتفي وقوف دوله
قطر الى جانب تركيا للتخفيف من التداعيات
الانسانيه الخطيره للزلزال كما اعلنت
الكويت عن تسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
تقديم مساعدات واتقوا من طبيه عاجله وقال
العراق انه سيرسل فريق انقاذ وستين طنا من
المساعدات الاغاثيه والغذائيه الطبيه اما
باكستان فقالت انها سترسل طائرتين الى
تركيا على متنهما مواد اغاثه وسته وثلاثون
فردا من فرق البحث والانقاذ في الاثناء
اعلنت الخارجيه الاذر بجانيه ارسال
طائرتين الى تركيا تنقلان مستشفى ميدانيا
ومساعدات طبيه وانسانيه عاجله